you know we all live in this attention
economy and what traffics is outrage
this ecosystem in which pushing buttons
and being oppositional rather than
solution oriented is what you know kind
of creates traction on the internet and
gets people innervated and energized and
all of that and to kind of stand as a
Counterpoint to that and say I'm not
going to be complicit in that economy
and I'm going to you know sort of stand
on my own two feet speak up for the
values that you know I espouse and
instead of casting aspersions talk about
Solutions is something that gets
denigrated in the algorithm doesn't get
the Mind share that it should so it's
the harder road that can be frustrating